and the big story no miguel cabrera he
is not scheduled to play in the finale
of this road trip happy john means day
17th start of the season five and three
very good era 2.7 84 strikeouts and just
70 inch pitch and you love the strikeout
to walk ratio
and grossman is punched out looking
pitch look to be a little bit inside but
means gets the call from adam hammery
for a lead off k there's a switch hitter
candelario and jamer of first pitch
ground ball to short martin a good clean
field and a strong throw from the
outfield grass
one two three first inning from the
orioles get ready to face the 23 year
old native of sacramento california matt
manning
mullen's looking to make it 19
right out of the chute he does just that
a lead off single for cedric mullins
his 40th hit in the first inning now
cedric mullins is on pace
austin hayes will continue his hit
streak
mullins gets to 19 hayes gets to 10.
throw nearly got away and it's a
career-high game hit streak for austin
this is trey mancini strike one to
mancini swinging the line drive caught
with a leap
by willy castro at second base
not hit especially hard he had to time
his jump and he timed it beautifully
this is a chopper in the shift and willy
castro he'll get one can the tigers turn
two yes they can
santander nicked it first four six three
to end the inning
orioles just in case want to take a look
and this play will be reviewed
[Music]
and if it is overturned it'll be first
and third two out
this is a quick review
he's safe okay so they pointed to second
base first for the outcall
collective hearts and throats
all around berlin
and cedric mullins at third base after
his lead off single santander is on the
move manning will throw back to second
now let's see mullins starting for the
plate here's the throw home he's going
to beat it he is safe
santander will hold it second
after a turn
but the orioles get a run out of
absolutely nowhere as cedric mullins
just baited his old teammate ronaldo
nunez into that one
mateo takes him out to right field
that's in front of robbie grossman
another base hit for jorge mateo who's
now three for nine in the series and you
know
a major threat to go
he was not at first very long he got one
heck of a jump he easily
easily steals second base
jump that was
here's the 2-1
lifted
to shallow right good running catch by
robbie grossman to end the ball for the
threats
up the middle to start the tigers third
pop up from grossman over first base
trey cannot get there
reyes will try to go to third mancini's
throw
got him
if the tigers have learned one thing the
last two games it's do not run on trey
mancini
hayes drives one to deep right center
field reyes makes the grab before
crashing into the wall
what a play around his face
what a play by victor reyes somebody
told you about that wall last night this
is a fun one to play you can go get on
your horse
02 to santander
right back to manning he'll go to second
for one the relay in time
nice double play started by matt manning
and finished by zach short leadoff man
who's aboard for the second straight
inning for the tigers here's jammer
candelario not a payoff
a bullet into the left field corner
that's a fair ball all the way to the
wall
scope is going to hustle and he will try
and score the relay is not in time jamer
candelario's got an rbi double and we
are tied at one
little boy candy candelario at second
base one out nato nunez steps to the
plate drives one deep left field that's
got kerry that ball's gone
renato nunez welcome back to baltimore
and he gives the tigers a 3-1 lead well
the man at first already three runs home
here in the fourth
reyes drives one deep left field that
ball is off the foul pole a home run a
two-run shot
second homer of the inning for the
tigers third homer of the year for
victor reyes he faces dj stewart to
start the bottom of the fourth
d.j stewart with a colossal drive to
right grossman does not even move
almost made it to utah street clanged
off defense but either way
long gone
second home run for dj in as many games
manning delivers the 2-2 and he blows
away mateo for his first strikeout of
the day
inside
three homers in the game so far
grossman tags one to deep left field
that ball is gone
robbie grossman belts number 18 to kick
start the fifth tigers having some fun
now their third home run in the last two
winnings back to a 4-run lead 6-2
six to two tigers oh two
stewart gets a hold of this one deep
left center field reyes to the wall and
it's a two homer game for dj stewart
anthony santana
with a two home run game on tuesday
dj stewart with a two home run game on
thursday
and look out world because dj is cooking
that one is up and in richie martin with
a one one-out walk against funkhouser
and the orioles have a little something
something going here in the seventh
on the ground pass to diving nunez pass
to diving castro another base hit for
cedric mullins
a three-hit game for cedric
martin motors to third and the orioles
are going to bring the tying run to the
plate hayes represents the tying run of
the plate austin swings and a fastball
in on the fists tigers get one and only
one hayes beat it out martin home on the
fielder's choice it is six to four as
hayes brings in a run
that one near the shoes it hit him it
hits santander on the foot and the
orioles have the lead off runner aboard
in the eighth
and the 1-0
grounded to third
around the horn castro's relay in time
and the tigers turn their second double
play of the day
and a big one to get fulmer out of the
eighth
through the right side a base hit for
ryan mckenna
and the orioles will bring the tying run
to the plate
barton off the end of the bat a late
jump for reyes from deep center this
falls in for a base hit and the orioles
will bring the go ahead and game winning
run to the plate hayes one for two in
his career against fulmer the 1-0 a
chopper
behind second the flip in time to get
mullins and the tigers boast their ninth
sweep of the season
they hold on and beat the orioles 6-4